Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this piece of work, we seek to control
digital characters in real-time.
It happens the following way: we specify a
target trajectory, and the algorithm has to
synthesize a series of motions that follows
that path.
To make these motions as realistic as possible,
this is typically accomplished by unleashing
a learning algorithm on a large database that
contains a ton of motion information.
Previous techniques did not have a good understanding
of these databases and they often synthesized
motions from pieces that corresponded to different
kinds of movements.
This lack of understanding results in stiff,
unnatural output motion.
Intuitively, it is a bit like putting together
a sentence from a set of letters that were
cut out one by one from different newspaper
articles.
It is a fully formed sentence, but it lacks
the smoothness and the flow of a properly
aligned piece of text.
This is a neural network based technique that
introduces a phase function to the learning
process.
This phase function augments the learning
with the timing information of a given motion.
With this phase function, the neural network
recognizes that we are not only learning periodic
motions, but it knows when these motions start
and when they end.
The final technique takes very little memory,
runs in real time, and it accomplishes smooth
walking, running, jumping and climbing motions
and so much more over a variety of terrains
with flying colors.
In a previous episode, we have discussed a
different technique that accomplished something
similar with a low and high level controller.
One of the major selling points of this technique
is that this one offers a unified solution
for terrain traversal with using only one
neural network.
This has the potential to make it really big
on computer games and real-time animation.
It is absolutely amazing to witness this and
be a part of the future.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, which
also contains the details of a terrain fitting
step to make this learning algorithm capable
of taking into consideration a variety of
obstacles.
I would also like to thank Claudio Pannacci
for his amazing work in translating so many
of these episodes to Italian.
This makes Two Minute Papers accessible for
more people around the globe, and the more
people we can reach, the happier I am.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!